I know that many of you made miracles happen to get to this day.
You've shuttled between challenging classes and Greek life.
You worked hard,...
...studying late into the night.
You've survived so much to get to this moment.
However you got here, you made it.
What you choose to do next is what we call in the movies the "character defining moment."
The stories you are about to live...
...are the ones you will be telling your children and grandchildren and therapists.
But seriously, I know that graduation speakers are supposed to inspire...
...and offer good advice,...
...but I'm gonna be honest.
The world is full of bastards.
You won't always get everything you want.
Life is like the Star Wars movies.
Some of it is great, some of it sucks,...
...but you have no choice but to sit through all of it.
The moments that really matter are the moments when life tells you no,...
...the days that challenge you to your very core.
So, don't lose hope...
...no matter how dark it gets...
...just please be honest with yourself.
Live your dreams, not the dreams of others.
Go out and do what your teachers and parents thought could not be done.
Congratulations.
Congratulations, Class of 2016.
Good luck!